رفض المحكمه الدستوريه البلجيكيه طلب
الغاء المعاهده المبرمه مع ايران حول
تبادل السجناء يفتح الباب امام امكانيه
عوده الرهينه
البلجيكيل المعتقل في ايران في مقابل
افراج بلجيكا عن الدبلوماسيه الايراني اسد
الله اسد المعتقل لديها افق يظل معقدا رغم
قرار اعلى هيئه قضائيه في البلاد سينيك
انها المره الثالثه التي تتخذ فيها
المحكمه الدستوريه قرارا يتناقض مع قرارها
الاول حيث علقت تنفيذ المعاهده في مرحله
اولى كان القرار مفاجئا نسبيا هذا الملف
يشهد التطورات الاستثنائيه واعتقد ان
المحكمه لم تتجاهل ضغط الراي العام لكنها
توصلت الى قرار متوازن
المحكمه الدستوريه رفضت طلب الغاء
المعاهده الذي قدمه ممثلون معارضه
الايرانيه قرار يمكن الحكومه البلجيكيه من
التمهيد الاجرائي لتنفيذ المعاهده
القرار يامر ايضا للحكومه البلجيكيه
بابلاغ ضحايا المخطط الارهابي الفاشلي قبل
الافراج عن الدبلوماسي المعتقل كي يتمكنوا
من التظلم امام المحكمه الابتدائيه
اذا خسرنا القضيه امام المحكمه الابتدائيه
وقمنا بالطعن في قرارها امام محكمه
الاستئناف فان ذلك لا يمنع الحكومه من
تبادل السجناء اما اذا خسرت الحكومه وطعنت
في قرار المحكمه الابتدائيه فلا يمكنها في
الوقت نفسه تنفيذ المعاهده بحكم وجود قرار
قضائي
امام الحكومه البلجيكيه اسابيع قليله
لتبادل وثيقه المعاهده الرسميه مع الجانب
الايراني حيث يستخدم الرهينه البلجيكي
ورقه مقايضه لاستعاده اسد الله اسدي ملف
معقد تداعياته تتجاوز حتما نطاقا العلاقات
الثنائيه بين بلجك وايران قرار المحكمه
الدستوريه يعكس الحرسه على انقاذ حياه
الرهينه البلجيكيه
من سجنه الايراني دون ان يتجاهل حقوق
ضحايا المخطط الارهابيه الفاشل الذي قاده
اسد الله اسد المعتقل في بلجيكا قرار لا
يحسم المعركه القانونيه بين الجانبين
نور الدين الفريد العربيه بروكسي